good morning I hope you're all more
awake than I am because I can do this
talk on autopilot because I've done it
before but there's bits in here that are
going to make your brain cells die
because what I specialize in is proving
who did stuff when things are anonymous
and it certainly spent a lot of years
making my brain cells die being able to
believe it really worked the only thing
that made me feel it really did work was
when the US Patent Office just let six
patents to her in six months I was like
okay we've got some people who actually
care about detail so this is never one
easy topic to give a talk on because
people people have very weird views
about what counts as trust and what
counts as identity and programmers have
this hideous belief that they are
entitled to data I know I'm just as
guilty of that I mean you can't build
stuff that you can't see the day to him
until you spent a lot of time scenes
building stuff you can see the data in
and hitting yourself over the head with
a brick back going I can still see it
why can't I give up on that and it's not
an easy thing to do
so I 1/2 of a team who threw absolute
mischance and a drunken night in 2003
the goth festival in Whitby in North
Yorkshire became one of the world's
leading teams in identity research there
aren't a lot of teams in identity
research so the bar for this is very low
on the other hand there should be an
awful lot more teams in identity
research because most people who are
doing it still think it's all about
tokens and numbers and facial
recognition all of which really sucks
it's not a very good way to do this
stuff my business partner is a
cryptographer he does the security I am
a physicist making things flow through
interesting higher dimensions is my
hobby the confluence of the two is the
confluence of two very disparate on the
surface areas of mathematics training in
universities that happens to turn out
when you get really down deep to be
almost identical it's just it takes a
lot of years to release
that and most of what we do is really I
guess experimental computer science
which is quite unusual because most
people in computer science found
interest in doing experiments where was
everything we do is experimental so most
of what I'm going to talk about has only
really been interesting interested to
the world large for the last couple of
years and that's because our dear
friends in the European Union have
decided that if it comes into the
European Union and it doesn't obey some
bureaucratic ideas of what privacy is
they're going to try and chase you for
money a lot of money now this is less
relevant to American companies because
you don't have these laws over here
unless you unfortunately have to play in
our bar the poisoned backyard of data
privacy but it's really only us in the
UK and the lasts two years basically
every company threw money around pulling
their hair out going how the hell do we
comply with this legislation they're
stuffing there no one can comply with
like black box databases and things like
that there is still a research topic I
normally will spend my time doing these
sort of talks there to a more general
audience I mean strange loop is the one
place by now I can really abuse people's
brains here and a couple of competencies
but most you can't normally I spend most
of my time talking about can we target
our dear friends anonymous and the fact
that you know there's all these bad
actors on the internet who are pawning
data I would talk about idea friends
with the UFO at GCHQ and their friends
electric over here who own Utah so a
store occasional databases in Utah and
then I would normally bring up some
recent hack Ashley Madison is obviously
very old now some recent hack and then
spend about ten minutes explaining how
BAM hit it you have to be to actually
want to store that data I'm gonna assume
that all of you already have those
opinions if I'm wrong that's fine
come on buy me B and we can talk about
it identity in the UK is sort of similar
and sort of different to identity in the
States and here I'm talking about legal
identity there's stuff that courts care
about the stuff that governments care
about I don't actually know what
particular documents you use over here
to prove
a person's identity I know that some
states at least have photo IDs
we have no photo ID in the UK at the end
of the war everybody went out and burnt
their identity cards and any government
ever since it suggested we should have
identity papers in the UK has basically
seen hits poll ratings go we don't like
the idea we're supposed to actually have
them now because European law demands
and every European citizen has them and
I suspect a large part of why we voted
brexit is actually to do with we don't
want to have photos on a piece of paper
that a policeman can insist we can show
which of these over here do you think is
a good idea proof of identity passport
may be the only one of these it's a
legal identity document in the UK step
one a deed of name change doesn't
require state involvement at all
requires one witness all you do is say
you're changing your name with that I
can get a passport without any further
investigation as we use some of the best
passport tech in world due to GCHQ have
been very very good at cryptography our
passport once you've got it is
incredibly trustworthy as not tampered
with except by a state actor however
this is in no way trustworthy it's just
a piece of paper with three names on
unfortunately most people who do
identity don't ever look at identity
documents they don't think about what
legally identity is now this is
frustrating because I really want to be
running around over there or possibly
over there so I have killed half killed
cameramen before by running around
faster than they could move the camera
most of the chatter these days in the
identity world is about things called
attributes and an attribute is nothing
more or less complicated than hair black
this is not new stuff
the very first handwritten paper
passports produced after the the
conference of Vienna in the 1830s had
hair black distinguishing marks tattoos
description of face ovoid
or intelligent or beardy these are
attributes effectively the digital world
is trying to reinvent the 1830s at
present attributes are not very
interesting
they're not very interesting for a
number of different reasons firstly
they're very small bits of data if I'm
going to give you a very small piece of
data over an internet connection
I cannot encrypt it very securely unless
I have buried it in a much larger
encrypted stream because otherwise I'm
probably going to have cutting errors
and all kinds of other little tricks
that cryptographers go
I'll find I know your data especially if
I'm passing around the fact that your
age is 12 age 12 is a very easy one to
gain because it's two digit number so
attributes on their own a fairly lousy
also attribute Tec when you view it that
way doesn't cope with blank attributes
very well a blank attribute is actually
a very valid data piece of data ok I
have dark hair I wear black I'm not a
professional cryptographer so that's not
my description that's my business
partners description but what if he
doesn't have any hair the value of no
hair is no hair none it is a nil value
ok that lovely thing that we all hate in
functional programming nil values so
attributes feel really bad way of
thinking about people on their own also
we live in a world that has become very
obsessed with the technology that does
not provide the anonymity that we keep
being told it does block check and I
can't really complain I use block
chaining techniques all the time in my
work I just don't like public block
chains because proof of work is
expensive and slow and tedious and
boring and eventually the world is going
to melt because all the computers will
be calculating what the next times
actually should be so we would ideally
like a world in which we're capable of
being anonymous in which we kept we'd
have that every day if I walk down the
street
currently I am not very anonymous
I'm making a very big point of not being
very anonymous and I'm on a stage in
front of an audience I'm definitely not
anonymous right but when I walk down the
street even in my hometown I am for the
most part completely anonymous nobody
knows my name or anything about me they
just see this blob of flesh walking down
the street in whatever state happens to
suit whatever time of day and whether or
not I clean out that night for a band or
something at which point it might not
look at all we distinguishable from any
other blob of flesh use it and that is
what we would like to have in databases
to protect us precisely because if we
don't have anonymity we have just become
the most monitored victims of panopticon
technology in history because computers
can do searches so bloody fast on such
large data sets the only true anonymity
can protect our data from somebody who
wants to correlate our lives and I'll
get onto that later
now this over here is still anonymous
that's just a face in the crowd but as
we add extra bits of data in we move
into pseudonymity this is what
blockchain section public blockchains
are mostly offering us
boom boom boom or that's me right
pseudonymity is not a good thing because
look at that I mean look at how much
data pseudonymity is giving away even
when it's only giving away that bit of
data there are only so many people who
joined Twitter on August 2007 and if
that can be correlated with any other
piece of data in my life suddenly
somebody can start tracking me in ways
that you do not want machines to be able
to automatically do unless you're China
I'm not China I wish had the budget of
China so I don't I don't normally put
put genuinely good literary quotes in
especially not hackneyed ones that
everybody knows normally I picked them
from obscure fantasy novels because it's
more fun but we have known about this
difference between names and things for
a long time we can take it back to the
bloody pythagorean's and there
everything is reducible to a number if
we really want to
that Vosges doesn't stop having all of
the attributes of a rose just because I
decide to call it a carnation or Albert
you know it still stays exactly what it
is it's of a certain particular
constructional form it's got certain
properties unfortunately that is not how
programmers think I know that because a
I've spent an awful lot of years as a
programmer and B I really did get quite
deep into object technology at one time
and as a sometimes recovering rubyist I
really do care about the naming of
things because if it's not just right
it's not catching what I really wanted
to capture and that's an artifact of the
fact we live in code which is a language
that only really has a literary form and
doesn't really pinion to anything in the
real world unless the computer does as a
result we have what our bottom level of
how we do identity in the real world we
have the idea of secure token so you've
got the whole bluetooth low energy light
let's tap our phones
I mean wicket there's a whole thing
called defy their alliance which for the
last 15 years has been trying to get its
particular international standards to be
the one that lives in all of our phones
and all of our passports secure tokens
aren't secure because they're not
actually something that comes from me
there's something I carry which means it
can be stolen
they've got digital content which means
somebody with the right equipment come
copy them and yes that's very difficult
and companies like DES Fire will assure
you their kit can't be gamed and it's
x-ray proof and all of this but honestly
have you ever actually tried to do that
with their kit have you been in their
fab plants and seen how to do it I
haven't I don't have confidence
therefore that what they say is true I
don't have trust in that well that's
okay because actually if if the proof of
who a person is has to come out of them
what about biometrics biometrics are
lovely aren't they we've all got them I
mean I'm not about to suspect change my
genetics my genes are what they are I
mean it's such a complicated bone pile
of stuff in there that nobody's going to
do the kind of tampering to be able to
replicate my genes in someone else well
that's true
but on the other hand they already did a
pretty good job of that for us so I
think it's something something like one
in a million people have the same
genetic fingerprint okay in the UK
that's somewhere between 56 and 72
people who have the same genetic
fingerprint on any other particular
sample that just happened to be picked
up at a crime scene that's actually
quite a big sort of thing if say they
all happen to be relatively closely
related which funnily enough does often
tend to be the case and they were all in
the vicinity of the crime at roughly the
same time which people who often live
together would be that genetic
fingerprint doesn't actually look like a
very good way of identifying sample util
oh and of course we we have got leave
the second order stuff where people have
become obsessed with electrocardiograms
electroencephalograms and all of that
it's true that there is behavioural data
that your body itself produces that you
can do interesting machine learning
models on but do we trust machine
learning models that much so in the real
world governments often try always
trying to tackle really this problem
it's really hard to government you do a
whole pile is stuff that you've been
asked to do by the citizens of your
state and you know you only really want
to do it for them because they're the
ones who are paying the bills and you
want to make sure that they feel they're
getting the service that they demand and
you're not putting them through too much
pain so bang along camp Eurocrats and
say well we'd have ID card sir
ID cards look lovely because all kinds
of complicated tech is applied to make
sure they can't be forged easily all of
it can be replicated
they contain biometric data which can be
tampered with and in general nobody who
ever presents an ID card anywhere has it
properly scrutinized by a person who is
properly trained in how to spot any of
that in other words ID cards are solving
entirely the wrong problem which is a
bureaucratic obsession so ID cards are
bad okay so let's say we have some
miracle way of doing identity online
let's say we've got it in our computers
and we can now actually be certain that
the still data we are taking at any
instant is valid trouble is really we
need to take data over time because if
somebody pumped in that still data
remember we don't control digital inputs
to remote systems we just don't so if
somebody pumps in that data and it looks
right well how are we going to spot that
it's not so we then have a whole field
that's growing up in recent years called
liveness liveness detection is making
sure that there really is a live person
at your handset or your computer or your
gate or whatever liveness is hilarious I
particularly love the iPhone hack at the
bottom because I do a present yeah
that's a bit ropey and so the the face
recognition algorithms it cheats but
you've only got a look at what's
happening with graphics cars design over
the long term you know we're getting to
the point where movies are going to have
artificial characters rendered in real
time with the whole body moved thing and
everything another ten years after that
if that's not in every phone it will be
surprising at which point phones are
perfectly capable of spoofing every kind
of visual data we would expect to get
from camera exploring a human being
so liveness itself is an absolute
nightmare to do and I'm going to get
onto solutions to all of these problems
in a bit because it's something I spent
a lot of years banging my head against
brick walls trying to solve we also have
what the what common wisdom now
considers trust this is where we move
into the blockchain world now Trust is a
funny old thing most of us when we meet
a new person most of the time trust them
to be telling the truth about who they
are and why they're there it's actually
a very important part of the whole neuro
social thing that allow society to
function if we never trusted anybody we
would be incapable of going into new
environments and having any kind of
meaningful interaction it didn't involve
hitting them with something for fear of
what they were about to do to us when we
misinterpreted some movement of this and
this is very yeah this is is one of
those things that to anybody designing
identity systems is a nightmare why
can't humans be like
that you know I mean yes we'd have to
make sure they never got within six feet
of each other and ban any kind of
projectile weaponry at all which means
even elastic bands but at the same time
we could rely on them not to give away
data they shouldn't not to trust people
they shouldn't because their default
setting would be so eat my firewalls up
no packets coming in instead that
firewall setting is all lock packets I
love those at alcohol or whatever other
recreational chemicals you can think of
and that goes from I love packets to
packet you're my best friend
Oh packets why won't you worm whatever
so forth stuff this thankfully for those
of us who live in common law
jurisdictions we can boil this down to
only one thing we care about for trust
only one thing it's something most
people don't know enough about and our
European friends have a very different
take on this the code Napoleon does not
believe that this is a contract but this
is a contract in the common law world
there's a hand there's a receipt there's
money that's actually a contract that
damn near what you think of is a
contract isn't a contract well it is in
some jurisdictions it isn't in others in
the UK that signature is entirely
optional we call it a wet signature and
there's no requirement for them none at
all a contract can be purely verbal and
that includes across the internet where
if your email client decides to just
append a pro-forma signature that counts
as you having agreed to whatever
contractual arrangement happen to be in
that email now this sounds like absolute
madness how on earth can that work
surely this means everybody's entering
into contracts all the time that are
about to get them in deep trouble well
yes but the reason why that one at the
top he is a contract that is impossible
is because there is evidence this one at
the bottom actually isn't evidence the
signature isn't very good evidence
they're easy to fake this one up here
involves two people in a situation where
they've exchanged stuff they've had a
knock on effect in the real world
they've probably got witnesses who have
seen them exchange stuff which now means
you can sit in court one person can
that's him you honor he dannion he never
gave me my such-and-such that he says
was coming from China within four days
and then the other party can stand up
but I didn't do that it's not me and
I've got 15 non friends of mine who were
in the Starbucks over the road all
spying on me who can all agree that and
that is how UK courts work that's how
American courts work although you're
more litigious over here about other
things but that is the essential of
contracts is there evidence see it
happen
now legally you have to go back from
that is there evidence there was intent
to form that contract well actually yeah
there there's a receipt and I've got
money in my till that's all the evidence
I need
so we're technologists we somehow want
to capture this mad bag of things at a
don't make sense B shouldn't be done
C have no real meaningful digital
reduction and we somehow want to shove
that through our crypto tool bag because
obviously we're going to use crypto
that's not because okay yeah it's cuz we
want to use crypto okay I'll be honest
you can't work with a cryptographer and
not wake up in the morning and go gee I
wonder what we can do with crypto today
he's not going to enjoy watching this
talk he never likes me talking about our
working relationship because it's like
but you're loony you don't know what
you're doing you give people the wrong
impression which I do do my best to do
so we have a very small tool bag of
stuff that we use for pretty much
everything we use I'm sorry I'm about to
make this camera I have to move it I'm
just I need to be over here briefly so
we have secure signatures
cryptographically secure signatures well
my hat md5 oh I'll get away from this
video it's a really bad missus catalog
it also happens to be a fundamentally
good cryptographically secure signature
if you use a H Mac with md5
oops wrong button over here we have our
good friend diffie-hellman which you can
teach with clocks I was really impressed
mice I've got a nine-year-old son and
when he was seven they were doing
modular arithmetic with them with clocks
and everything I was great for the first
time in life I was actually able to
explain to somebody who was at just the
right point with what they were doing
how the stuff I do a lot of the time
works without having to make them
unlearn all the other stuff they've
learnt after that and it lasted for like
a week and then they've ruined him they
took him off into something else and it
was like that was it we also have the
most useful thing in the whole world of
cryptography she had secrets our good
old friends symmetric crypto now
everybody is obsessed with asymmetric
crypto because you've got really big
keys and symmetric crypto is incredibly
fast it's much stronger for its bit
length than anything that you will find
in the asymmetric world and frankly it's
the only thing you need if you really
have to pass data but guess what most of
time we don't want to pass data we want
to pass proofs we want to build a small
data playbook with the other side of
whoever we're talking to that's part of
how we know we trust them because they
understand what we say to them and then
the only things we want to say are
proofs lovely things I might actually
end up a mathematician at this rate
which is really if my math teachers from
from high school could see me or be like
but you were bomb at everything and I
thought I can't even do proper calculus
I somehow faked my way to a physics
degree without you can haven't proper
understanding of calculus so my dirty
secret now we have one interesting bit
of bit of knowledge and I'm for the
moment going to leave this at face value
if there is a unique mapping between a
piece of data and a very large random
number there is no way to actually
figure out what the message being passed
is without having that map
okay and I'm going to leave that as
fundamentally true for the moment it
isn't as fundamentally true Shannon
thought it was but it's a good starting
point uniqueness has been something that
our friends in the intelligence world
have been loving since at least the
1890s and possibly going back a lot
further than that but you you get the
first real one-time pad usage there and
sort of the eighteen nineties and it
revolutionized cryptographic messaging
between agents in the field and their
handlers we also interesting
immutability we want to prove after
we've done an exchange with someone that
what we sent them is what they received
and there's no way we can have tampered
with it to make it look like what they
got isn't or that they could have
tampered with it to make it look like
what they got was we want to prevent
forging and that's what immutability is
all about there is an entire industry
built on this one simple understanding
of functional link
one-way linked lists that's really all
the blockchain world is doing its
functional lists that happen to have
proofs in there is no magic we also want
to prove the integrity of that series of
receipts for want of a better word
because we want to show that they turned
up in the order we claim they did and we
want to show that they got broadcast in
the order they claim we claim they did
and we want to make sure nobody can in
to interject their own versions of
messages to corrupt a ledger we're
moving into the world of accounting this
is accounting 101 keep two sets of
Ledger's make sure they match up it has
the rather entertaining name Merkel tree
I'm going to show you something later
that I call a Merkel forest which is
basically just let's plant a lot of
trees and see how they grow together
nicely architect you in this world is
actually not that difficult as long as
you've got the right primitives if you
approach these kinds of problems as we
have to invent everything from bait from
you know basic arithmetic or something
you're really screwed but if you just
come up with some things that have good
real-world analogs and you can actually
under
those analogs you can actually do a lot
of transport architecture very easily
blog chaining is really just sticking a
series of lows Merkle trees of in a
linked list with a proof of the Merkel
tree which obviously is the top node so
and it's got a few things that go wrong
obviously if your Bitcoin you're in a
distributed system so you need to
consensus algorithm but that's
incredibly expensive on communication
and the other interesting properties of
it and also in the case of Bitcoin Forks
can be a bit of a I'm gonna be careful
in my language because I promised I
would an issue I have a more fruity
anglo-saxon word I normally use for that
the final thing is we have to get these
proofs around
we need to route stuff we need to move
stuff over live networks the moment we
step off our machine until the moment we
step onto somebody else's machine we
have no control over what's happening in
between we don't know how many nodes
we'll go to we don't know who's looking
at those nodes we don't know if perhaps
an entire network segment is completely
compromised by somebody with more
computing power than we have and
therefore more capacity to undo what we
have done then we have to do it and
obviously we have some interesting stuff
going on in the routing world I mean
everybody's familiar with tor which may
or may not have massive holes in it I'm
personally suspicious of anything that
comes out of the US Naval Observatory is
a as a secure communications mechanism
if it's going to be used by the general
public because I wouldn't as the US
Naval Observatory want the general
public to be beyond my ability to see
that's just me being honest about the
fact I quite like peeking inside the
data which is the worst possible thing
you know we all live a bit like it we've
all a bit peruvians in the way we
approach life ultimately we need to find
ways that even if we move through really
hostile nodes we can do so without
anybody spotting what we are doing I'm
going to speed up so
my claim to fame is I devised an
identity system that worked having had a
previous claim to fame that I must have
devised at least a dozen that didn't
it's not quite as fast as inventing the
steam hammer because unfortunately the
iteration cycles on identity systems is
much slower mostly because there's a lot
of arguing with other very clever people
and the more clever people in the room
the less likely the solution will
actually turn out to work in my
experience so we devised this little
thing and it has we have a set of
principles behind it mostly we do we
just don't want the system to be survey
labelled we wanted to allow law
enforcement to arrest people who've
committed fraud but we want you is the
person who's the victim to be the
trigger for that happening we don't want
the state to just go oh well we can spot
all the frauds anyway because quite
frankly that's not how our legal systems
in common law jurisdictions work it's
completely I could see why you appear in
country might go for that but in the
anglo-saxon world that doesn't really
fit our legal tradition in fact it runs
so counter to it I can basically and we
only had one wheel requirement for this
system our one requirement was can you
prove that a random person over the
Internet he's 18 the actual person not a
machine thereon not the credit cards
owner for the card that they're using
but them and this was this is actually a
very important commercial thing in the
UK because a few years back and this is
this is quite funny really because I
never thought I'd end up working on
something that's main use case was porn
but not really my area of interest but
there was a very famous case involving
Playboy TV they had for years been
taking credit card imprints to allow
their users to access porn over the
Internet
the laws always said it has to actually
be a proof of the person being over 18
and not anything else and it finally
that the regulators knew there was no
solution to the problem so they took an
awful long time to get round to finally
letting this come to call but he came to
court I think it's 2015
sat there the High Court a judge says
well clearly it doesn't comply with the
law
bang at that instant and this is still a
nun self problem really as far as the
the porn industry is concerned cuz they
don't really like the solution that we
came up with and the client we did it
for is actually more interested in
grabbing students for student housing
long story
but anyway since then they've been all
been operating illegally
they've been allowing people they're
still getting to their sites on credit
cards and the regulator is saying you
know often says that's very naughty of
proves that you're trying to do
something to solve this and it's so so
that was our one thing is somebody over
the age of eighteen I know nothing else
about them I want to know nothing else
about them I only have to show the
regulator proof they will over the age
of eighty nothing else out of that flows
the entire system now that didn't the
system architecture over those kind of
dull you know you've got an anchoring
system you've got a secure store which
I'm not going to go into detail about
right now but it's inferable from the
mess and you've got anger against
something in the real world so the only
proof of being over 18 we have in the UK
is a passport or possibly a driving
license well people who have driving
licenses don't always have photo ID
driving licenses I mean my partner's got
a 25 year old paper driving license it's
still family valid and legal it's got a
massive set of holes in the middle that
make it almost unbeatable but it is a
valid driving licence and has no desire
to get one with a pretty picture of a
face on so so that wasn't really a good
choice because we'd have to deal with
random documents with holes and no
photos or anything okay
then we're back to the deed of check to
the chain deed of change name so the
passport is the one thing you can hang
on you've got two things you can do you
can anchor on an OCR scan that is not
actually a very good anchoring those are
tangible much very easily tangible but
you know what
most of the world is letting people in
and out of their countries based on
grainy photo okay so it's not about
there's also a whole pile of digital
stuff in there I mean a lot of countries
now have e passports there's a massive
great big ICAO Stan
that's almost completely
incomprehensible and sent me to sleep by
page 3 which my business partner is an
expert on but most countries don't apply
it correctly so for example UK passports
don't reliably give you an actual photo
now for the purposes of doing stuff over
the internet your face is what I really
need having your fingerprint isn't very
useful to me because I don't have a
trusted fingerprint reader but I do have
a camera most of the time in your device
so I want your face we don't want to
store any of the detail about you though
so there's a whole interesting pile of
stuff that then has to go on
so the registration is kind of dull I
mean this is what comes business is
obsess over are we getting the right
data but it's really not very
interesting to me what's interesting to
me is this transactions see you can have
an identity system in which absolutely
nothing is known about you and you're
completely untrusted when you first come
into it but if your behavior in the
system is going to build up some kind of
blockchain a blockchain I don't need to
be able to see I don't need to see all
to see who you've transacted with I only
need to know those transactions are
going on and I need them to be able to
see whether or not other people have
trusted you which is a very different
question then over time even though I
know nothing about you you can become a
very trusted actor you can become
somebody the whole world will go
absolutely solid if you were Chyna
social social credit rating whatever if
you were the UK your Experian value
would be really good and you're likely
to get a car loan so different
priorities and there's a little bit of
magic down at the bottom which what
tickles me is the fact this can be done
with photons the patents describe it in
UDP packets because it's the smallest
you're going to do in a computer system
in the modern world but this can be done
with slightly coloured photons
interacting I give you something a big
vandamm number that I can only use once
you combine you it's a big random number
that you can only use once and you give
it to a black box storage service that
knows nothing about your details it only
knows your random numbers and then it
gives you and me together right it gives
us two halves
proof that that transaction happened I
get the half related to you you get the
half related to me so like we just
changed it basic I I've effectively
patented a quantum business card it is
nothing more complex than that
the math behind some of it is
nightmarish but as a result we can now
start to build up an entire
infrastructure around this concept
that's just transactional nothing else
anonymous blackbox transactions now I
say there's I want your face though why
do I want your face because the only use
case for the data that you've got for me
and I've got from you is in a court and
I need to be able to show a piece of
evidence the you that I interacted with
whether locally or remotely was the you
that that actual large random number was
associated with and the easiest way to
do that is actually to store a face now
most people want to sticks faces in
searchable databases they want to be
able to go find the faces the index and
there's a there's some fine tech for
that I have a friend who can do 4,000
face matches a second on his Dell laptop
using a bit of technology a little trick
called an L BP at local binary pattern
they're incredibly accurate they're just
it there with in point two of a percent
of the accuracy of actual commercial
facial recognition systems but the
trouble is I don't want to search on
your face it's none of my business is
that black box provider you want to be
able to show the photo the other person
in call with a barrister or lawyer as
you call them out attorneys you called
me and I want my barrister whose main
skill is making people sweat when
they're lying to be able to say are you
honestly saying mr. or mrs. so-and-so
that this beautiful glossy 1920 by 1080
photo of you with the spec thing down
the left side of your nose from your
Rosicrucian whatever are you really
telling me that this was not you that my
client was cheated by and then nine
times out of ten that person is going to
be so packing themselves they're going
to go honestly it wasn't me and the jury
is going to go you're shifty you've done
it and that's what we called court tests
you only think we care about
however you and I when we transact week
a lot more than that we want to swap
some information sir I'm an automated
system I need to know you over 18
actually I don't want you to tell me
you're over 18 I want to know your I
want to know your date of birth I want
to calculate that for myself it's an
important scaling reduction on the
central server I do not want a dynamic
interpreter in the middle of a black box
datastore even as a rubyist but also at
the same time you need to active on your
own process to confirm for yourself that
the data you're getting gives the answer
you want that's not my business my
business is making sure that the proof
is there when you need it that that was
the data and so we we reframed attribute
based systems in terms of profiles
profiles are basically nothing more
nothing less than a webform there are
key values a key value set I don't
really understand why the attribute
world can't get its head around the fact
that you can have three separate
separate values for name in a particular
piece of data they just really won't get
their head round there I think there's
too many engineers involved for once of
a better term but as a result of this we
we have the underpinnings for the proofs
we have the way of transmitting data we
have no insight into that data so off to
a really good start from an idea system
if the police kick our door in and take
our database good luck
every single bit of data in the system
and the only trick for the secure store
is this every single bit of data was
encrypted with a different key and the
only two parties who have the key for
the encrypted data are actually the two
people are just transacted and the
shared key between them is actually the
transaction ID it's just a really big
vandamm number that would may or may not
be used again there's an interesting
point there if you never use the number
again actually your system is less
secure but if you do use the number
again your system is less trustworthy if
you never use it again you see you just
opened yourself up to a whole new class
of traffic analysis attacks because
every time that number is seeing that
number now defines that record so this
when I say that Shannon is true up until
the point that's because Shannon wasn't
thinking about these things happening in
large networks that might have repeated
randomness
so we added in this idea of confidence
which is really just a stolen credit
score from Experian basically let's run
an experience style credit scoring
network it just happens to be on if
you're trustworthy and transactions
always say that is Experian pity they
didn't patent it first really and then
we've got these things receipts now
what's cool to me about receipts is
actually this entire structure is just
quantum entanglement it doesn't look
like quantum entanglement because people
get horribly complicated explanations of
this at university but quantum
entanglement is really just two bits of
data that funny enough if remotely and
happen to be correlated and the odd
thing in our system is it's a frozen
entanglement
there's no way to D entangled the data
because of the blockchain which itself
is another blockchain down these block
chains which is hopefully I'll get on to
in a second so yes what we are doing
over here is you do the transaction
there's this bunch of data that's the
actual stuff that flies backwards and
forwards between you this here Maps back
to your previous transaction the other
person's previous transaction which are
black boxes to us but we can allow
somebody who's got a whole set of those
transactions to come back and see
whether or not that set correlates with
any that the partial evidence so it's a
partial derivative attack basically for
face recognition well I've said some
mean things about face recognition but
the LBP stuff is fascinating and the
only bit of a face that really matters
for voice recognition is this here
that's it that's the only bit that most
algorithms really focused on
liveness though liveness though is a
nightmare there's actually really no
very good method when you just think
about faces to come up with the way of
proving a face is life oh look it's
moving what a video clip would move the
only way you can prove a face is live is
to trigger at least two events with a
random set of parameters that you
provide and make sure the data that
comes back correlates with the two
random events well we've got a bit of
smoke and mirrors going on here we use
pupil dilation which is a known fixed
response curve and a couple of flashes
to effectively cause the pupil to dilate
twice and we take photos of that or
video of it doesn't really matter that's
not actually how we proved aliveness I
mean it's this is a timing pulse this is
just putting a clock in the system
nothing else
timing pulses are really good if you can
find places for clocks in your systems
do they're lovely
I love clocks what got me into geekdom
in the first place was disassembling
every clock in the house and not being
able to get most of them to work ever
again
this down here is how we were actually
doing it we're actually using properties
of the eye moving during this time cycle
this time window to follow an elliptic
curve that's used to generate movement
data for piece of text on the screen the
elliptic curve is a shared secret you
need to just your handset for you and
our central server for communicating
with the random numbers that you're
sending in to prove you you so as a
result we get a genuine biometric
likeness as long as we can take your
face and we can send our two pulses
needless to say it took a hell of a long
time to come up with that and I have to
for the timing post I have to thank a
friend of mine George oz who being a
miss applied cyberneticist who dropped
out of medicine we're just like I know
what we can do to put that clock in if
you want a clock we can play with
people's pupils so it differs depending
obviously on their intoxication state
but the response curve still produces
the same characteristic form
it device liveness though now this is
something nobody else talks about
because nobody else can do it and it's
not because it's difficult it's just -
nobody else actually seems to care
nobody cares about weight or not the
device that I'm getting your data form
itself is alive I'd love to be able to
do some kind of electrometric that would
actually tell me it was your chip and
everything but as of yet I just don't
know how to do that that's gonna be
years of I mean I saw an interesting
black hat black hat talk actually in
which guy manages to tease the Machine
registers to tell him about this little
embedded processor inside an x86 chip
that via make and I can't help but feel
there might be something there but it's
below my my competence level yeah I go
there I don't go in there
but do they take to your your device is
life I need to actually get signals from
your over more than one network loop and
I need to actually get that yet again
within a time window now that's going to
fail a lot of the time because the
internet is really lousy transmission
mechanism on occasion as I always find
whenever I travel when I need it most
but we can do this little thing that
allows us to effectively use the
biometric likeness to send back its data
through two completely different
out-of-band channels combine them in a
way that only we know how the internal
routing for that works which is why the
MGT are stopped ciose to me and then we
can say yep your device is life and then
we can say your face is live and then we
can say you've got the right random
number and then we can give it to the
other party now this stuff unfortunately
slows down the beauty of the four UDP
packet well that's three UDP packet
sequence which is about as minimal as
you can get I can't think of a way of
getting momentum of that but as a result
you can do an entire identity set and
this is the only talk in the world that
will show you how to do an entire
digital identity stack from scratch I
hope it was worth the 12 years of my
life is taken to figure this how because
I've had a lot of this at home about why
I didn't get a proper job finally to add
a few bits in so one of the one of the
junior programs he was working on that
project well now actually starting to
implement it spotted it effectively you
could man in the middle of website
because we were using the mobile phone
to actually set up identity
so we're scanning something out of a
website of course you can man in the
middle of
so this little thing this allows us to
actually force the remote server to log
into our phone and gives us a secure
back channel so we can now monitor what
should be on that screen effectively
anytime you can get a secure back
channel get it because now you can
monitor what's going on and more to the
point now if my son is viewing porn on
the internet from his his device I can
have that all set up so my phone gets
the back channel I can say no your
bloody not and lock him out so it's a
logout effectively as a lookout button
for a second system this one I'm always
in two minds about whether to include in
this talk because effectively this tells
you how to break the entire system this
is where we're entering the world of
traffic analysis or flow analysis
depending on how you prefer to name it
so the reason that Shannon breaks down
is Shannon wasn't thinking about the
statistical properties of a whole pile
of different communications or going on
at the same time and the more slavishly
you will follow Shannon the more you
build up these big spikes saying I don't
know what you're saying but I know
you're saying something so everybody has
probably heard the story of NIC mo and
how we cracked the Nazi codes and how we
won the war that wasn't how we won the
war there was a little Hut at Bletchley
Park called Hut six run by a chap called
Gordon welchman and all he did was map
out the entire European axis
communications network and then just
watched how all of that traffic was
going on and correlated that data with
random bits of intelligence from the
field that actually told us an awful lot
more about what Germany was doing and
what Italy was doing than any broken in
chrome enigma cipher you know and that
was stuff that could be running 24/7
that's your actual life monitoring
system so that's actually the world we
live in on the Internet there are actors
who are doing that some of them are
actors that I approve of them doing it
because they're doing it for the right
reasons so others who are not doing it
for the
reasons many of them have private
sectors sort of actors who aren't doing
it for the right reasons and if we can
protect our users from that sort of
thing it's our obligation to do it
because otherwise we're giving them a
false sense of security and that's the
worst sense of security there is if you
want to find out more our website is not
very informative
we always start up self funding in aro
effectively in our own bedrooms Chris
last thing you want we've got a new
system that basically is completely
unlike this one and this is four year
old research which if I can talk about
in now but if you want to find out how
to have lots of fun playing with crypto
and networking I have loads of slide
decks explaining how to do it in Ruby
and how to do it and go we should do
languages I mostly play with there's
some other stuff in there as well about
privacy and so forth
[Music]
there are also at least I think 11
patent applications in the USPTO that
are all public domain which is the other
reason I can talk about all this stuff
because it's the first time I've ever
worked on an identity system that wasn't
under commercial confidence and NDA's
this one is in the public for those who
hate patents ILO's the patent system but
that allows people like me to tell you
how stuff that you would never get a
chance to hear about works somebody
think of a better way of this happening
place I lost 18 months of my life to the
patent system it isn't easy
thank you very much being a good
audience and for only a few of you
disappearing off and I hope you have a
good conference
[Applause]